non-minimalists
sometimes i'm at odds with what to do
with the things that i want to get rid
of especially clothing
um i have a hard time sometimes giving
to goodwill
and salvation army and places like that
because i know that
any of their surplus sometimes well
most likely ends up in other countries
and messes up with their own economies
and i wanted to know if you have any
suggestions for your listeners on where
they can
give their stuff to people in need if
there's
places that they can look for in their
own cities
and towns that um would actually benefit
the people locally instead of
abroad so sheila this is a fascinating
question because
i think a lot of people deal with this
obviously you know they regret the stuff
they have now or maybe the stuff was
even useful for a period of time it's no
longer serving a purpose
it's no longer bringing them joy and
they don't want to put it in a storage
locker in perpetuity
and so what do they do with it and quite
often
the answer is well i guess i'll go to
goodwill or even worse i'll go to like
the gas station there's these little
bins where you can throw
clothes in there and we're not really
sure where it goes it's just this
this hole that we take our stuff to and
i can understand the concern because
it's not serving a purpose now but she
wants the stuff to maybe add value to
someone else's life
what do you recommend to people like
this i and i know of a few resources
that i've recommended in the past but
i'd love to know what you think about
what people should do with their
unwanted stuff
well i have to say my new favorite thing
to do with myself my kids is to go
shopping at vintage clothing stores
and one of the best ways in in kind of
creating that
um beautiful array of choices
is to consider selling your your
clothing that you don't need anymore to
companies like real real
they'll give you the money for it and i
think that the money that i
i receive for most of my stuff i give it
back to larger charities that then are
able to serve the population with
many things so it's almost like
sometimes that really special pair of
levi's jeans might be worth
way more money that you can make a
bigger impact with by donating it to the
charities that are out there to support
you know vulnerable families with the
clothing and the needs that they might
have
so i think there's a lot of value
sometimes in the items that we have held
on to for so long
that the the dollar amount might
actually do more good
and then you're supporting a whole new
industry that actually
i think is something that the future of
environmentalism is going to
really be uh digging into is that
vintage clothing
second-hand shopping you know don't buy
new kind of thing
so i love that yeah my wife and i
there's a vintage shop we went to an
atwater village
maybe a couple years ago now and i was
just shocked by some of the pricing
that that these items demand and it's
because it is something that is vintage
that someone wants of course
don't get caught up in the sunk cost
fallacy you may have paid 100
for a dress that is worth next to
nothing now and it's probably better to
let it go
uh if you can't sell it you know my
personal rule is a 30 day rule if i'm
unable to sell something
now i like the the uh the the
consignment shop because real real
is is a consignment shop right some
things aren't that expensive there too
by the way
right right and what i found is that you
know
even if i'm selling a piece of furniture
or whatever quite often consignment
tends to be the best option because
you're outsourcing that to someone else
then if i were to just get on craigslist
or
ebay i know for the longest time if
anything was
i thought worth more than 20 i would try
to sell it on ebay especially when i was
trying to get out of debt because
i wanted to to get the money that i
could from these resources i was no
longer using
so i could apply it to this debt and i
could experience some some freedom there
but by by letting go of the stuff
eventually i realized that a lot of the
things i
i couldn't sell at all and so um the
resource that i often use if you're
unable to sell it or if a consignment
shop won't take it there's a
website called donationtown.org i'm not
sure if you're familiar with them
but um it's a you just go to the website
and
it will find local charities some of the
big ones of course are going to be
mentioned there like goodwill salvation
army or whomever
but uh i found a lot of local charities
where i've been able to donate stuff
even things like mattresses where
you it's really hard to get rid of a
mattress usually but they'll use them
for for people who really need a
mattress or
your furniture or different appliances
even clothes you can go to
donationtown.org you can even find
places
that will that'll pick up
larger items from from your house
depending on what area you're in you can
do a sort of zip code search there
and i think that'll that'll help you out
a lot rachel one more thing i can also
add is
a lot of the schools that we've served
in the past the
families there there are many families
who are homeless actually and if they're
under this title one kind of bracket
many of the families are living under
the poverty line so the principles of
those schools
tend to accept things so in your local
area
at crayoncollection.org we actually have
a school finder where you just enter the
zip code and you can go in and find
either a head start school or a title
one school
and you can contact them and they will
most of the time take almost everything
that you've got
um it's there's so much need out there
it's unbelievable
but if yeah like like you said if the
good stuff gets sold take the money and
donate it to the charities that can then
do more with it but if you can't sell it
and it's something that you know you can
donate locally i highly recommend
checking out your title when schools
nearby
when my mother passed uh it was my first
foray into minimalism
and uh a lot of her things i i knew i
couldn't sell
it they weren't worth anything and so i
was able to donate those to friends and
family locally
but there were a few things i was able
to sell and i took that money and gave
it to the two charities to help mom
through her chemo
and radiation treatments and so you know
paying it back or paying it forward in a
way
to to help other people in need yeah i
think that's really important in the
school thing it's
it's a need we don't even think about
yeah but of course
it would make sense that they have the
means to redistribute there
and to people who are actually in need
so it's not just going somewhere that's
going to be stored in a warehouse
forever rachel i'm going to send you a
copy of our book essential it's an essay
collection
and it really talks about being
intentional one of the essays in there
is about clothing it's called the
favorite clothes of a minimalist but it
really talks about
being intentional with the things we
bring into our life because then we have
fewer things we have to try to sell or
let go and in the future
if we're really intentional about with
what we bring into our lives so we'll
send you a copy of essential if you want
the ebook or the audiobook version those
are the most sustainable versions
i think you would argue um then we'll be
happy to send those to you also if you
want the print book
we're happy to send that to you as well
rachel thanks for your question